is that what people these days it's
still not as bad as like the Bratz dolls
when they came out in the 90s or
whatever the L was hello everybody my
name is markiplier and welcome to the
visitor this is a game
alright then anyway I actually don't
know all that much about this game it
came out on Newgrounds awhile ago and I
did not play it but I do know that you
play as that itty-bitty little worm
because I loaded this up before and
tried to find out a little bit more
about this game so what I've gathered is
that you are a worm and you have a quest
and you're supposed to do a thing and
meet someone somewhere I don't know
where but here we go
so you click on things in the
environment and they do things but they
don't always do the things you want them
to you need to click them in the right
order
like oh my god this frog ain't too happy
about me clicking on them but if I click
on this branch and then I quickly hop
over to the branch and then I click on
the frog something interesting will
happen wasn't that interesting ladies
and gentlemen anyway this is described
as a point-and-click style horror game
and that's as far as I got so now it's
all intuition and instinct from here on
out I'll have to live by my wits and be
an alien worm I'm assuming I want to
either eat or be eaten by things to
evolve myself to become a thing okay so
what do I do now ooh Rock splash what Oh
fish ooh no okay come on come on I see I
see that fish well yeah poop okay I see
the fish being splashed out of the water
what does that mean for me okay there's
got to be something else oh maybe he'd
be interested in that it's a weird
combination of things sometimes I would
have thought that the fishing pole would
have been something more akin to what
that would be however it can be very
hard to find exactly what you're
supposed to do split oh yeah you like
that lake you like that this is totally
inappropriate for children actually not
in any way it's a rock in a lake get
your mind out of the gutter
ignore what I was saying get your mind
out of the gutter oh oh oh there we go
okay got it
okay so the bird was supposed to go over
there and eat all the bugs coming out of
the tree that are trying to get to the
blood of the frog so what does that mean
whoa what does that mean for me
how's that dude do I need to get that
bird do I need that bird is that bird
something I need oh now I can do the
thing because the birds gone okay so
there's an odd combination of oh okay
all right that makes a little bit more
sense so that means I can get nut and
work okay oh okay whoa what how was I
supposed to know that was what you
wanted me to do I thought you wanted the
worm to eat the fish or something I
didn't know who's gonna launch myself
into another dimension all right okay
hello kitty you seem to be eyeballing me
rather precariously you're smarter than
you look I'm evil but I'm gonna eat you
or something along those lines okay so
what do I do about this Hey hi wanna
mess with me I'm an alien worm what do
you think I'm gonna do to you really
really key to get really okay
fine then I'll just I'll be on my weary
way weary way okay bye wait what am i
doing now don't even think about it
Hey good of us with you if you don't
mess with me so hey I don't mess with me
all right so what am I supposed to do
now if I kink I think I'm supposed to
get in the hole in the wall so I can get
in the building but I think I've got to
do something to make this cat less
appreciative of what's going on in life
oh oh okay that's really interesting cuz
the shadow of the branch was shown I
wouldn't have known that unless I would
been a little bit more intuitive about
gaming and use my language it is
debatable
little better nevermind whoa what the
hell whoa that's cool
it's a puzzle okay so why so where am I
supposed to launch myself off to so that
alternates between that wookie whoa wait
a minute what the hell why did I come
back here Hotel no no no is there a
reason the cats but oh no oh okay I hope
you all enjoyed that one yeah that poor
kitty cat I knew it was gonna happen but
geez why did it have to be like that and
it was not a lot of information going
from one point to the other I mean if
that was my end objective why didn't I
let the thing just eat me like the Frog
maybe because I would've chewed me up
into little pieces
click hey what do you think you're doing
she okay so I need to do something with
a knife but there's also a dog over
there who doesn't seem too angry my
presence honk okay honk hey can I put
another India No all right so I'm gonna
blend up this Oh No
Namah change the thermostat do this oh
oh you saw that you did that's too bad
honk hey ain't you worried about this Oh
No ok so damn it okay so if there's got
to be something like under the cabinet
that she's blocking at the moment
like get to once she's gone there we go
there we go there we go gotta gotta
gotta gotta gotta BAM wait aah aah I
know what I need to do so I need to
throw this in here do I need to do
something horrible basically hit get
this and then open that and she's in a
concur head BAM
oh no wait oh come on you cannot be that
resilient it's got to be a combo here
this this that's the knife come oh
alright even that was surprisingly
effective okay so now that that is done
I could hop up on the counter change
this way up that flowers now blow and
which was my primary objective from the
get-go so now that I know exactly what I
need to do I can continue my the dog
doesn't seem worried at all and I don't
even know why he should be extremely
worried maybe so now what Oh Oh hooray
I did it what did I did okay
I can't click it up anymore I can't seem
to click on anything anymore
whoa that's good ah here we go whoa BAM
I'm like spider-man with my tongue it
gets you if you know what I milking
anyway oh these poor people that is a
disgusting fish
alright clunk hello everybody don't mind
me I'm just a horrifying alien worm
that's probably gonna invade that guy
through his big gaping mouth hole
mom oh oh I hate that the face is still
on the edge of their that bird seems a
little worried oh no bird okay well bird
not gonna be okay but bird okay for now
all right okay hippity hop the oh is
that enough to lure you mr. birdie don't
worry I'm only an alien worm that's
devoured everything up until this point
come on no you're gonna get it you don't
like a little tongue lashing do you okay
fine then I'll figure out another way
there's gotta be another way maybe if I
just smack you around enough you'll come
down you'll be daunted ha ha
the perfect hiding spot the bird would
never know the difference
all right so that's another bird Oh Oh
that's normal denied no I didn't need a
Pirtle ray the bird out front in the
first level of the game
oh no no his face exploded why does his
face explode I see a little bit of the
element of the Frog but god damn alright
if it's a guy I just noted that guy
who's awake I'm so sorry
don't worry that's not blood dripping
down from the top bunk oh yeah
bakit Oh
what oh that's the end
what is that got to be the end of it man
oh man okay it said that there are
multiple endings but I don't know how I
would possibly be able to get multiple
endings it's gotta be like something
wait why would I don't want to
Oh flag I guess I could flush the toilet
that's that's really useful for me I
don't know what to do I don't know what
other all right hang out I'm gonna try
to find something here your one thing
okay so I looked up a walkthrough
there's a way for the last guy not to
die but it involves clicking a lot of
things so here we go you're supposed to
click the door first
nevermind that didn't work out at all
hey you didn't give me enough time how
those I supposed to be able to do that
oh do I have to go through the whole
game to get to that again god damn it
okay your toilet paper toilet handle
bathtub cabinet door hairdryer outlet
faucet sink
gun clicking three times click on twice
to crush yeah
take that you murderous monster I did it
I got one of the alternate endings
there's actually another here so I'm
gonna just hang on one little second
here ah oh no no I clicked the wrong
button I click the Run button
Oh peace [ __ ] peace be right back
oh I have to relive that see mm-hmm
okay door uh it's my bad okay I cannot
click on the same damn thing again I
gotta do this right or else I'm going to
kick myself and honestly that took like
two minutes to get through all that when
you know what to do these things go
rather quickly okay that toilet will it
flies
okay all right so I get that comes such
an idiot god damnit you know what's the
cat but seen again
[ __ ] oh here comes the airplane ah okay
door toilet paper toilet handle bathtub
cabinet door hairdryer outlet bathtub
ah what are you still dead okay
alright alright I don't have to relive
any of the horrors again that is all the
innings there are only three so I hope
you guys enjoyed this video there is a
sequel to this I found while looking for
this game so if you want me to play that
let me know in the comments below I'll
probably give it a look if there's
enough demand for it or on my Play
because I was actually really
interesting really fun kind of kind of
like the gory old style horror movies of
the past well I mean there's gory horror
movies of the now but I mean it was kind
of had that reminisce and feeling like
oh you know we're all trapped in a cabin
in the woods even though they're
probably at a house in the suburbs but
anyway hope you enjoyed it check out the
other videos I've done in these same
style of games before I mean even the
house is technically a point-and-click
cell organ so thanks again everybody for
watching and as always I will see you in
the next video
by the cannon fire first good okay I'm
not going down there ever oh god damn it
bringing me out man what with your hands
already glowing job get a co hell no see